[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques des sur ces sujets
sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon à tomates dans
la crise ducobu 19
c'est toute une chaîne décisionnelle
médicales administratives et politiques
qui est responsable du ch est alors que
l' oms recommandait le port du masque
par les populations la parole publique a
longtemps menti sur sa nécessité pour ne
pas avouer la triste absence du stock
regret la décision de confinement
s'imposait compte-tenu du manque de
matériel permettant d'autres solutions
mais en freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise les connaît l'état ne pourra
plus être l'état providence que nous
avons que khurram aura été cimetière de
certaines espérances en pensant que le
progrès faisait de nous des hommes dieu
et que les technocrates avec les du
monde demain les conséquences de la
crise oblige à repenser nos modèles la
découverte du télétravail l'intérêt de
consommer des produits locaux le besoin
de solidarité vont faire évoluer une
population qui a découvert qu'elle était
mortel
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec à nos
invités tenus à bonne distance et nos
reporters sur le terrain
voici les titres de l'actualité
l'om est s'annonce ce soir la reprise
des essais cliniques sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine quant à olivier verront ils
demandent des explications asile n 7
après son étude contestée sur ce
médicament
la revue médicale qui a rétropédalé
mettant en garde contre son propre
article publié le 22 mai texte qui avait
conduit l'organisation mondiale de la
santé à suspendre temporairement un
essai clinique et la france à mettre fin
à l'utilisation de la molécule dans les
hôpitaux pour traiter le qu'ovide 19
le préfet de police de paris a réalisé
un signalement auprès du procureur il
intervient au lendemain d'un
rassemblement interdit de 20000
personnes à paris mais y ait deux heures
une mobilisation contre les violences
policières en mémoire de dame à traoré
morts il y a quatre ans après son
arrestation
le ministre de l'intérieur qui sauvent
castaner promet je seek une sanction
pour chaque hôte ou mot raciste dans la
police
[Musique]
aux etats-unis la crise sociale qui n'en
finit plus 8e nuit consécutive de
manifestations suite à la mort de l'afro
américain john double avec le 24 mai
lors d'une intervention policière
les tensions qui ravive la lutte donald
trump joe biden dans la course à la
maison blanche sur la question du
déploiement de l'armée évoquées par le
locataire de la maison blanche le
ministre de la défense
il dit lui opposé
nouveau coup de tonnerre donc autour de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine la revue
médicale dilemme cette rétro pédaler
prend ses distances avec l'étude qu'elle
a récemment publié à propos de ce
traitement controversé contre locaux
vides 19 après les avoir suspendus l'om
s annonce ce soir la reprise des essais
cliniques avec cette molécule
les explications de thomas boni la
publication de cette étude avait eu un
impact considérable le rétropédalage
auquel on assiste désormais pourrait lui
aussi être lourd de conséquences pour
bien comprendre revenons d'abord sur le
contenu de cette étude aujourd'hui
désavoué paru le 22 mai est basée sur
l'analyse des données de milliers de
patients à travers le monde les
résultats affichés dans la revue
britannique
dillon 7 attestent de l'inefficacité
voire même de la dangerosité de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine dans le
traitement contre le coc u19 voilà
qu'ils devaient mettre un terme au débat
qui déchire la communauté scientifique
depuis des semaines c'est en tout cas en
se basant sur les résultats de cette
étude que l' oms avait décidé de
suspendre les essais cliniques avec
l'hydro xi chloroquine en france le
ministre de la santé s'était saisi lui
aussi très rapidement des conclusions
pour annoncer sa décision suite à la
publication dans silence est d'une étude
alertant sur l'inefficacité et les
risques de certains traitements du coc
vite 10,9 dont l'idh roxy chloroquine
j'ai saisi le haut conseil de la santé
publique pour qu'ils analysent et me
propose sous 48 heures une révision des
règles dérogatoires de prescription ce à
quoi le haut conseil de la santé
publique avait répondu en recommandant
de ne pas utiliser l'hydroxyde
chloroquine dans le traitement contre le
coc u19
alors qu'on pouvait penser le débat clos
coup théâtre ce mardi avec la
publication de ce communiqué sur le site
de zealand 7
nous publions une expression
d'inquiétude pour alerter les lecteurs
sur le fait que de sérieuses questions
scientifiques ont été portés à notre
attention nous mettrons cet avis à jour
dès que nous aurons de plus amples
informations
une mise en garde qui fait suite à de
nombreuses interrogations qu'avait
soulevées l'étude du
de mes questions autour des données qui
ont été récoltés est question aussi
autour de l'intégrité voire de l'
expertise de la société surkis fer qui a
traité les informations médicales en
question après la parution plusieurs
voix s'étaient élevées au sein de la
communauté scientifique notamment celle
du professeur didier raoult si vous ai
passé quatre mille malades dans les
mains croyez pas que je vais changer
parce qu'il ya des gens qui font du big
data qui est une espèce de fantaisie
complètement délirante qui prend des
données dont on connaît pas la qualité
qui mélange tout comment voulez-vous que
une étude foireuse fait avec les big
data change ce que nous en vous
si ce rétropédalage du land cette donne
raison à ceux qui critiquent l étude
il n'indique pas pour autant que
l'hydroxyde chloroquine est efficace
contre le coc vie de 19 en revanche il
se pourrait bien que la revue médicale
soit contrainte de se rétracter
concernant cette étude
alors ce revirement est il en mesure de
modifier le choix du ministre de la
santé
réponse de la porte parole du
gouvernement le ministre de la santé a
écrit en fin de semaine dernière à la
rédaction du land 7 pour lui demander
une relecture des données brutes telles
qu'elles avaient été livrées dans le
cadre de l'étude que vous citez je
voudrais également souligner que les
autorités sanitaires en france ou à
l'international se sont fondés sur
différentes études pour prescrire le
fait qu'il devait y avoir une suspension
des essais cliniques sur les drogues si
chloroquine donc ce n'est pas sur le
seul fondement de l'étude du lancet tu
que cette décision a été prise mais de
son côté l' oms a annoncé ce mercredi la
reprise des essais cliniques sur
l'hydroxyde chloroquine une preuve que
si elle n'était pas l'unique source
cette étude du land sept avaient eu un
rôle prépondérant dans l'utilisation de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine et pour en
parler nous sommes avec thierry lardeux
noah médecin généraliste président de la
caisse autonome de retraite des médecins
de france bonsoir monsieur l'art de noix
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors c'est un feuilleton à
rebondissements décidément l'om est ce
qui annonce ce soir la reprise des
essais cliniques sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine ça ressemble
voilà un vrai cafouillage a pour le
moins oui c'est un cafouillage et puis
alors
il va m'étonner mois terriblement c'est
que le ministre écrivent aujourd'hui
pour demander aux lans est des comptes
sur cette étude
j'ai envie de lui dire monsieur le
ministre que ne l'avez-vous fait plutôt
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas demander aux
lans est une expression correcte et
approfondie de cette étude avant de
suspendre les essais thérapeutiques avec
cette hydre cible en chine
n'at-on pas fait perdre des chances à un
certain nombre de patients en suspendant
ses études aussi rapidement ça moi c'est
ma question et c'est pas la seule c'est
pas la seule parce que moi je
m'interroge pourquoi depuis le début
s'acharne-t-on à instruire qu'à charge
contre l'hydre aussi clan qui c'est à
dire que on ne seconde journée c'est
uniquement d'utiliser les dents de scie
chloroquine dans des phases de la
maladie où on sait pertinemment qu'elle
n'est plus efficace et toutes les études
sorte à charge évidemment puisqu'on
l'utilisent dans des phases tout ça ne
fonctionne pas moi je m'interroge
pourquoi monsieur le ministre n'utilise
tons pâles hydroxy chloroquine et ne
fait-on pas des essais comme le
professeur comme toul a proposé à la
phase initiale et comme je voulais
également pour monde pro noms proposés
sur un essai compassionnel puisqu'on ne
vont vous proposait que les médecins
essayent de façon compassionnel sur
eux-mêmes hydroxy chloroquine et
l'azithromycine pour voir si ça
fonctionnait je m'interroge pourquoi ça
n'est pas fait je m'interroge
vous vous interrogez mais quand on
s'interroge souvent on a des débuts de
réponse selon vous le ministre de la
santé a pêché parfois par excès
précaution par excès de crédulité quand
il a lu cette annonce sachant qu'il est
évidemment médecin lui-même où il y
avait d'autres peut-être motivation de
la part de ministres voire d'autres
pressions l'a séduit qu'il faudrait
interroger moi je ne me permettrais pas
de mettre en cause un confrère
j'ose imaginer que en tant que médecin
il a à coeur de soigner les français et
que c'est son c'est le coeur de sa
volonté le coeur de les choix qu'il a
fait le coeur des engagements de sa vie
donc je ne me permettrais en aucun cas
de mettre en cause je je m'interroge je
me dis pourquoi une telle puissance et
un tel acharnement à discréditer cette
molécule est à aucun moment de se mettre
en situation de vérifier des hypothèses
- quand quand une hypothèse se présente
dans ma vie professionnelle ou dans ma
vie personnelle je me mets en état de la
vérifier et puis
ça fonctionne pas effectivement ça ne
fonctionne pas là on se met dans une
situation où on sait que ça fonctionnera
pas et on dirait que vous avez vu ça
fonctionne pas oui bien sûr on n'en ont
sans doute moi je sais ce que j'ai dit
sur une autre chaîne de deux médias
c'est à savoir qu'un étudiant de
troisième année de médecine
c'est très bien qu'on utilisera une
molécules antivirales au tout début de
la maladie et que ça ne sert à rien de
l'utiliser enfin de maladies au milieu
de maladie la phase d'état est une phase
dépassé en ce qui concerne les
pathologies virales c'est connu c'est
pas quelque chose de spectaculaire a
encore une fois n'importe quel étudiant
en troisième année de médecine peut vous
fournir cette réponse
donc quand on voit que absolument tout
le monde s'acharne à l'utiliser enfin
d'évolution pour nous dire qu'elle sera
pas efficace ce que l'on sait
parfaitement il n'y a pas besoin de
faire les études pour ça je m'interroge
alors c'est vrai qu'on nous a aussi dit
certains scientifiques derrière on aura
un invité tout à l'heure scientifique
lui même laurent alexandre qui voilà qui
exprimait des doutes puisque plusieurs
scientifiques nous ont dit voilà c'est
potentiellement dangereux notamment sur
l'aspect cardiaque
ça c'est pas sérieux c'est pas sérieux
on est sur une molécule qui est en vente
libre le 13 janvier vous allez le 13
janvier la pharmacie vous acheter quatre
boîtes vides rôti chloroquine on vous
les donne sans vous poser de questions
le 14 on voulait il faut une ordonnance
et le 15 mars vous ne pouvez plus la
voir même avec une ordonnance mais il
faut savoir que jusqu'au 13 janvier
c'est une molécule qui apparaît dans les
années 50 et qui est donc a été prescrit
à 1 milliard 500 millions d'individus
si jamais la molécule était dangereuse
ça se saurait ça serait ça serait ça
serait assorti de façons de faire sont
pas tant que ça c'était accusation n'est
pas sérieuse et elle ne tient pas la
route
d'ailleurs si on revoit les ont fait une
méta analyse des renseignements de de la
haute autorité de santé
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya en 2017 si mes
souvenirs sont bons jusqu'à 2020 il est
décrit deux accidents graves à
l'hydroxyte le rock in dont une
intoxication volontaire et là encore une
fois on sait parfaitement la dangerosité
de l'i36 chloroquine en intoxication
volontaire puisqu'on sait que c'est une
molécule qui présentent un danger mais
comme beaucoup d'autres comme beaucoup
d'autres je peux je peux vous citer une
dizaine de molécules qui sont vendus qui
sont prescrites chez des patients et si
on les utilise à des doses papa très
importante
on a des accidents graves et mortels ils
sont toujours commercialisés
donc le sérieux de mettre en cause
identique euro qui ne tient pas la route
ça tient absolument c'est un problème
purement franco français on rappelle que
de nombreux pays dans le monde
mais quand on regarde moi j'exerce en
moselle ont si on compare la population
de moselle la pente la population du
luxembourg elle à peu près équivalente
et la mortalité est cette fois plus
importante en moselle
c'est quand même et manifestement
luxembourg a utilisé les tropiques le
rocking de façon plus ou plus ou moins
discrète il ya il ya un problème avec
l'hydro xi clan qu'il ya un problème non
pas de la molécule non pas de son
efficacité
mais il ya un problème il existe une
chape de plomb sur son usage problème
politique
certains ne veulent pas qu'on utilise
cette molécule pour des raisons que
j'ignore ce que j ai il c'est pas mon
problème
moi je suis médecin généraliste vous
savez mon idée à moi c'est de me dire
quand un patient est malade je le soigne
mois mais même moi poignet mais m n'ont
pas appris à attendre les autorisations
de l'om est ce d'ailleurs qui va dans un
sens marche avant marche arrière ou
d'attendre qu'un ministre me disent oui
vous avez raison vous allez fais moi je
suis dans un bureau avec un patient qui
est malade il faut qu'en dix minutes
j'ai une réponse efficace pour le
soigner et qui durent donc moi j'ai
appris à traiter des patients comme ça
en trente ans d'exercice je crois qu'ils
ont été globalement satisfaits et des
piles et puis voilà
merci en tout cas de série alors donnons
un médecin généraliste président
également de la caisse autonome de
retraite des médecins de france d'avoir
été avec nous nous avoir apporté votre
point de vue et les avis des
scientifiques divergent eux aussi
toujours autant sur l'utilisation de
cette molécule les explications en
images
[Musique]
non
l oms annonce donc ce soir la reprise
des essais cliniques sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine après les avoir interrompues
suite on le disait à l'étude du land 7
en france la molécule à elle était
interdite également le 27 mai
aujourd'hui olivier véran demande des
comptes à la revue alors cette
interdiction est elle fondée sur des
faits objectifs le ministre de la santé
est il allé trop vite peut-on parler de
choix politique fait l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
gilbert collard député européen sur la
liste du rassemblement national bonsoir
gilbert collard merci d'être avec nous
c'est côté ou plutôt face à face laurent
alexandre ancien chirurgien essayiste
bonsoir à vous aussi laurent alexandre
merci d'être là
alors allons droit au but messieurs en
interdisant l'utilisation de cette
molécule en france la semaine dernière
ce que olivier verrons a fait une faute
gilbert collard selon vos jeux je crois
qu'il a lui même admis sans le vouloir
qu'il avait fait une fois depuis ce
qu'il a déclaré ce n'est pas parce
qu'une étude est contesté qu'elle est
contestable
pourquoi donc alors puisqu'il est
l'auteur de sept de 7 de cet aphorisme
avoir immédiatement interdit les
toxiques lockheed
c'est incompréhensible et ça pose quand
même plein de questions d'autant plus
que comme on l'a dit depuis le début de
votre émission
ce médicament était en vente libre
depuis 70 ans et a été administré plus
d'un milliard d'individus et que jamais
on n'a eu de retour négatif donc on se
pose vraiment la question pourquoi sur
la base d'une étude de violence est
aujourd'hui critiquée par deux ans est
lui même en a pris la décision immédiate
brutale d'interrompre la possibilité
d'avoir recours à ce médicament prison
en même temps quand même et ça c'est pas
négligeable à mes yeux le médecin le
généraliste du droit de prescrire ce qui
me paraît bon de prescrire moi je
pourris médecine libre je ne suis pas
pour une médecine technocratique et je
pense que monsieur vers a commis une
erreur d'appréciation grave qu'il doit
de grèce
le pense alors actuelle regretter
puisque l'om s annonce la reprise des
essais cliniques ce qui est quand même
très significatif à laurent alexandre
vous ne faites pas partie des grands
défenseurs de cette molécule vous avait
alerté voilà sur ses dangers en tout cas
d'en inviter à être prudents plusieurs
fois sur cette antenne
aujourd'hui quel est votre sentiment
avec ce cafouillage
on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas de consensus
entre les médecins entre les chercheurs
entre les pays si c'était une molécule
extraordinaire qui guérit les malades
il y aurait pas de débat s'il ya débat
c'est parce que l'efficacité de la
molécule est très faible ou nulle et
qu'elle a possiblement des effets
secondaires
il y aurait pas débat il n'y a pas des
pays sadique qui veulent tuer leurs
citoyens il ya des pays qui ont interdit
la molécule dans cette indication
c'est parce qu'on a des inquiétudes
parce que les bleus scolari vrai ces
molécules sont des molécules ancienne
mais monsieur collard il ne faut pas
oublier que les effets secondaires d'un
médicament varie d'une maladie à l'autre
si vous et moi on prend de l'aspirine il
va rien se passer
mais si on a une hémophilie on va faire
une hémorragie grave on va mourir donc
les effets secondaires des médicaments
vous voulez que je dise non mais vous
pensez que le médecin l'économie a parlé
de seconde
les effets secondaires de l'inrap sic
rocklyn de l'hydroxyde chloroquine dont
ce virus
on ne les connaît pas encore on sait par
exemple que dans le chikungunya la
chloroquine aggrave l'état des malades
dans le sida la chloroquine marche très
bien en éprouvette
mais chez les malades elle augmente la
quantité de virus qui est produit par le
malade
donc il faut faire attention ce n'est
pas parce que cette molécule est
efficace dans le paludisme beaucoup ou
dans les rhumatismes inflammatoires
qu'elle va forcément être efficace sinon
j'espère mettre à l'arrêt une question
pour vous oui maître collard wikio mais
oui
je vous êtes vous avec le respect que je
dois à l'homme de science moi je ne suis
qu'un patient qui n'est pas un patient
de l'être croyez moi parce que quand je
vois le cafouillage je m'inquiète un bon
mais la polémique autour de lui donc si
chloroquine elle a été construit de
toutes pièces
à un moment donné on ne sait pas
pourquoi on a pris la décision en
janvier 2020 d'interdire sa prescription
avant ça ne posait pas problème et vous
semblez dire si je suis je me méprends
vous me corrigerez bien sûr vous semblez
dire qu' il ne faudrait pas prescrire ce
médicament parce qu'on ne sait pas quels
seraient les effets retour sur locaux
vides 19
mais jusqu'à présent elle a été
prescrite
on n'a pas eu d'effets retour que je
sache
alors pourquoi cette espèce de 2,2 de
crainte que que beaucoup de médecins
n'ont pas eu pour le médiator par
exemple par exemple mais pour moi c'est
la trame près ce qu'on veut pas on veut
pas une deuxième affaire médiator n'ont
pas donné mais moi j'ai une question à
vous poser il ya quand même de nombreux
pays dans le monde
pardonnez moi depuis oui il ya quand
même de nombreux pays dans le monde
utilisent cette chloroquine et en france
ça sans me poser de multitude de
problèmes avec des débats sans fin
comment vous vous l'expliquez vous
effectivement laurent alexandre le
médecin vous savez c'est très simple
d'abord on est dans une ambiance qui est
très passionnel raul n'est pas à une
personnalité totalement simple donc ça
un petit peu pollué le débat quand il
expliqua pujadas il ya quelques jours
que pujadas ne peut pas comprendre ce
qu'il dit et qui lui dit pour nous
départager pour savoir si mon médicament
efficace au port va faire un sondage
voyez on est plus dans la politique que
dans des relations sérieuses il
s'aperçoit finalement la mairie de lons
a pas de molécule à cause de la
personnalité de le dr
non non mais il a beaucoup politisé
beaucoup personnalisés
mais l'humain et le sujet on peut pas
dire qu'il n'a pas été reconnue par
l'état puisque macron est descendu le
voir à marseille ce que mc rhône a fait
avec aucun autre chercheur donc au
contraire raul a été câliner par le
pouvoir et il ne faut pas oublier que le
responsable de la communication de raul
tu yanis roussel est très proche dans
marche donc on ne peut pas dire que le
pouvoir ma chronique n'a pas dit mot
en quoi ce que vous direz vous
parce qu'il faut bien comme ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que les
médecins ont beaucoup de mal
individuellement à retrouver les effets
positifs et les effets négatifs des
molécules
on a un exemple très très cruel en
médecine qui est l'exemple des anti
arythmique dans l'appart us du myocarde
100% des cardiologues dans le monde dans
les années 80 pensait que les anti
arythmique était bon pour les malades
qui faisait un infarctus qui on a fait
un essai clinique versus placebo en
partageant les malades en tirant au sort
les malades entre ceux qui avaient le
médicament et le placebo
et puis on s'est rendu compte que les
malades qui prenait le médicament mouret
2,7 fois plus que les malades qui
avaient le placebo ça nous est très
difficile à nos médecins de juger de
l'efficacité des effets secondaires d'un
médicament sur la base de nos seuls
patients
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que l'on fait
des essais cliniques qui sont longs
laurent ils sont internés mois en vidéo
vous êtes son analyse du rassemblement
national la patronne de votre mouvement
s'est exprimé aujourd'hui olivier vers
on s'est précipité pour interdire le
traitement à base d'hydroquinone au
rocking tout cela sur la base d'une
étude frauduleuse dénoncé désormais par
de nombreux scientifiques
est ce que le ministre de la santé ou
celui des lobbys est ce que vous
partagez la suspicion de la patronne du
rassemblement national parce que c'est
vrai que ce beaucoup ressorti cette
affaire de conflit d'intérêts de lobby
est ce que vous vous êtes aussi dans
cette suspicion c'est la partage
d'autant plus que j'ai fait mes débuts
il ya une dizaine de jours où je compare
et je la chine les l'industrie
pharmaceutique aux marchands de canons
ils ont ils dit nouri n'ont qu'une loi
c'est celle du fric et il est vrai que
l'hydroxyde chloroquine coup de
quat'sous et j'ai très peur que l'on
veuille l'éliminer ce médicament au
profit d'un médicament qui sera
peut-être le même mais qui coûtera
beaucoup plus cher
on sait que le gouvernement pardonnez
moi mais c'est important que le
gouvernement pousse le cynisme à vouloir
privilégier un médicament qui pourrait
perdre de temps qu'il serait plus cher
ou profonds en défaveur d'un médicament
efficace donc l oms financière non c'est
la question est bien de postes mais ils
appuient le patron de 207
j'ai oublié son nom excusez moi je ne
suis pas scientifique a lui même reconnu
que le poids des lobbys pharmaceutiques
étaient telles qu'il ne pouvait plus
avoir de communication scientifique sur
parce qu'il y avait un tel un tel lobby
une telle manipulation dans les travaux
qu'ils n'avaient plus de certitudes il
l'a dit lui même c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est lui à partir de là on peut
parfaitement imaginer que des gens de
bonne foi se font manipuler mais si
souvent manipulées sont pas à leur place
un mot tout à l'heure sur ce que disait
mon mon excellent contradicteurs il m'a
pas échappé que il l'a quand même
adressé une pique à la personnalité du
docteur out
je pense que ce médecin hors norme qui a
découvert je crois 12 médicaments quand
même sauf erreur de ma part dérange le
conformisme des autres voilà d'un seul
coup il a atteint une notoriété
bon c'est ce que c'est que les baux des
uns et des autres dans tous les dans
tous les domaines et je que je pense que
véritablement il y a à la fois
combat contre le médicament pour des
motifs qui peuvent être très honnête
c'est certain et très malhonnête chez
d'autres mais que la personnalité
écrasante de cet homme qui n'est pas
dans le moule qui n'est pas dans
l'académisme dérange aussi qu'il fait
des jaloux il fait des jaloux
narcissique y voit là aussi c'est le
monde de la médecine et comme le monstre
du barreau et comblement des médias ont
une personnalité un peu énorme ben elle
dérange crée des jalousies pourquoi
avoir évoqué docteur tout à l'heure le
fait que la personne qui s'occupe de la
communication de raout appartient à la
république en marge
en quoi ces scientifiques comme
observations en quoi laurent alexandre
la tra référence alors je n'ai pas dit
que c'était scientifique c'était juste
pour dire que quand on dit que macro ne
l'aiment pas macron adore raul t il
s'est même déplacé à marseille a reçu de
réponse au problème des lobbies
alors d'abord préciser que moi à titre
personnel je jure sur l'honneur de
n'avoir aucun conflit d'intérêts ni avec
les fabricants de la chloroquine ni avec
les les fabricants d'éventuels
concurrents de la chloroquine je n'ai
aucun conflit d'intérêt je le jure sur
l'honneur mais aujourd'hui il n'ya pas
de lobby contre la toux rauque in parce
qu'aucun autre médicament ne marche
c'est bien notre dame la chloroquine ne
marche pas et les autres antiviraux
hélas ne marche pas le remdh et et vire
de gilles ead ne marche pas et personne
ne l'utilisent
il n'y a aujourd'hui aucun antiviral
hélas ce qui marche on a espéré que le
remdh et y virent qui étaient des bleus
qui a été développé pour les sièges
vraiment magique et notamment la fièvre
ebola est la sienne marc burg pouvait
marcher
et il ne marche pas donc aujourd'hui il
n'y a aucun le biais à la manoeuvre
parce que les malades qu'on ne met pas
souple eurokin on n'aimait pas se joue
notre molécule à la place on les met
sous rien on les réanime on leur fait un
traitement symptomatique
mais on leur donne pas de médicaments
puisqu'ils n'y a aujourd'hui pas
d'humour 432 son efficacité notre monde
sait maintenant c'est la réanimation qui
a tué beaucoup de passion beaucoup de
mal
il ya plein d'études à dormir debout non
non c'est la réanimation qui sont des
malades ne versez pas c'est comme si les
viera puis les corps
docteur je veux pas jouer les
médications je serais mal mal placé mais
il ya eu des études là dessus ça a été
dit ça a été dit qu'est ce qui a été dit
que de réanimer les balades qui allait
très mal les tuer que la non venue la
chercher des bâtisses je n'ai pas dit ça
alors vous dit les marques
j'ai dit que de passer immédiatement à
la phase de réanimation sans passer au
préalable par un traitement ad dropsy
coquine et aux antibiotiques mais la
lettre
franchement non là franchement je vous
assure qu'aucun médecin ne passe sont
malades en réanimation s'il n'y a pas
besoin de le mettre en réanimation
nous admirons les relations uniquement
uniquement les malades est en état grâce
au traitement décent mais quel
traitement si demain si devant un malade
un du gorille m demain ou si mes enfants
le truc au vide et là je prends du
paracétamol aujourd'hui la chloroquine
la motion demande parce qu ils sont
médicaments très juste dire un truc
oui mais ils brigueront terre on se rend
pas compte à quel point la situation est
difficile et complexe dans ses
incertitudes
et franchement olivier derand a fait un
boulot super moment le 2 de l'accuser
d'être dans la main des lobbys ça ne se
vend pas cool parce que merci à vous
deux je perds cola à l'autre sans
alexandre avoirs des banques est avec
nous dans quelques instants à nous
reviendrons sur la mobilisation
interdite en raison du contexte
sanitaire hier à paris en mémoire
d'adama traoré jeune homme décédé en
2016 après son interpellation
une affaire qui fait écho des c'est
évidemment de djordje floyd aux
etats-unis la crise sociale se poursuit
là bas avec une 8e nuit consécutive de
violences
[Musique]
ça fait maintenant plusieurs jeux des
décennies presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait à gauche dans le projet politique
la recherche n'a pas la place qu'elles
devraient avoir parce que la recherche
est un élément central dans la prise en
compte et très très grands défis face
auxquels nous sommes aimés en
particulier le défi qui fête ses
conséquences et notamment les problémes
ni là c'est la première mais qui va y en
avoir d'autres
il faut qu'ils aient pris de conscience
collective vraiment on vit tous les
jours sans faire attention que tout en
dépend c'est l'unité de mesure de toute
chose une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france 20h30 heure de paris la question
à des violences policières on débat au
lendemain d'un rassemblement interdit de
20000 personnes à paris manifestation
organisée par le comité de soutien
d'adama traoré émaillés de heurts pour
le seul responsable des billets
l'allemand selon les mots dassa la soeur
du jeune homme tué le préfet de police
de paris qui a par ailleurs fait un
signalement au procureur de son côté le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner selon trois ferme
il faut faire en sorte que chaque faute
et il peut y en avoir
chaque accès chaque mot y compris des
expressions racistes fasse l'objet d'une
enquête fasse l'objet d'une décision
fasse l'objet d'une sanction et je suis
sur ce sujet intransigeant parce que et
l'exigence que nous avons vis-à-vis des
policiers qui faudrait c'est garantir
justement la sérénité du travail de
l'ensemble de la police et de la
gendarmerie c'est garantir la défense de
cette police républicaine qui au
quotidien combat combat le racisme
combat l'antisémitisme et s'engage au
quotidien pour défendre l'honneur de la
république nombreuses réactions la crise
politique la droite dénonce des
manifestations inadmissible le ps
appelle lui à ne pas maintenir jusqu'au
31 août l'impossibilité de manifester
pas un mot pour adama traoré
pas un mot pour reconnaître le problème
des violences policières
pas un mot pour dénoncer les pratiques
discriminatoires pas un mot pour
répondre à la demande de justice de
milliers de manifestants
on dirait du trump j'ai commencé à
militer à 14 ans j'ai rarement vu autant
de monde devant un palais de justice
je n'arrive pas à respirer ce n'est pas
un slogan c'est une réalité que vivent
trop d'habitants la peur de mourir en
raison de sa couleur de peau justice
pour adama il y a quelques semaines si
on oublié son attestation en allant
chercher du pain ont risqué une amende
de 135 euros
hier on a laissé 20000 personnes
s'agglutinaient dans paris on ne peut
pas utiliser une souffrance pour la
transformer en haine contre une société
un jour viendra où les irrédentismes
identitaire biberonné depuis
cinquante ans à la haine de la france
par le pouvoir anti national se
soulèveront pour mettre notre pays à feu
et à sang
le gaucho progressisme nous mène droit à
la guerre civile
il regarde les états unis avec espoir en
voyant les images d'incendié de casse à
paris autour d'un rassemblement interdit
je pense aux malheureux commerçant qui
ont vécu la crise des gilet jaune puis
le confinement qui subissent à nouveau
ces désordres insupportable le droit de
manifester n'autorise pas tout émeutes
et tensions ethniques aux états unis ont
aussi responsables politiques qui
tentent de propager l'incendié jusqu'en
france
les contrevenants à l'interdiction de la
manifestation prévue ce soir à paris
doivent être arrêtés et sanctionnés
l'extrême gauche se complaît à diviser
les français en alimentant le
communautarisme le racisme anti flics la
haine anti france irresponsable face à
un pouvoir incapable d'assurer l'ordre
juste seule solution
l'assimilation à la communauté nationale
des policiers se seraient présentés au
domicile dassa traoré cet après midi sur
quel motif est encore en république que
ces intimidations n'empêche pas ceux qui
demandent justice pour adama de
manifester pacifiquement la vérité la
justice la paix triomphe toujours
attention on cherche à travers la sphère
traoré par le biais d'une expertise
faussement indépendante à transposer les
troubles que connaît l'amérique dans une
france déjà explosive pourquoi cette
manifestation pourtant interdite at elle
eu lieu hier éléments de réponse avec
alexandre langlois secrétaire général du
syndicat vigie police il y avait vingt
mille manifestants donc ça fait du monde
ça fait beaucoup de policiers mobilisés
après il ya toujours des choses qu'on ne
comprend pas donc là la question à
savoir pourquoi ça n'a pas été empêchées
faudrait poser la question à monsieur
l'allemand à la préfecture de police
ce qu'il y avait quand même des
effectifs de police qui étaient déployés
à proximité les services de
renseignement avait bien précisé que
rassemblement avec du monde
du coup après les questions de notre les
ordis rares chic c'est faut poser la
question des fois on ne les comprend pas
nous sur le terrain mais s'ils avaient
vraiment des raisons il aurait pu
autoriser la manifestation c'est
toujours plus facile d'autoriser pour
avoir des contacts dans les chais les
manifestants et donner un message un peu
plus pacifique
et puis d'avoir aussi les effectifs
autour pour bien contrôler autorisé ces
contrôles et là c'était interdit donc
c'était quasiment incontrôlable en
savait que ça allait mal se finir dès le
début quasiment donc après on ne sait
pas pourquoi n'est pas intervenu
pourquoi ces politiques est ce qu'il y
avait assez de monde de surplace déployé
ce qu'ils avaient peur de ce qui se
passait aux états unis que ça fasse la
même chose en france il ya les
explications sont à demander à monsieur
le préfet de police sur le terrain on
est un petit peu dépassé sire que soit
la manifestation est interdite de
placement là on fait tout pour
l'empêcher
soit elle est autorisée en l'encadré là
on était dans une situation dit l'un et
l'autre ce qui était incompréhensible
d'un point de vue légal
ray pour en parler nous sommes avec un
guillaume martin avocat et membre de
l'observatoire parisien des libertés
publiques bonsoir guillaume martin merci
d'être avec nous une première réaction
de votre part la mobilisation lierre est
ce qu'on aurait pu dû éviter cela
le fait est que on savait au moins dans
la journée même les jours précédents
qu'il y aurait une forte mobilisation
pour ce rassemblement
que cette mobilisation serait forte
indépendamment d'ailleurs de la décision
du préfet de police d'interdire ou
d'autoriser cette manifestation
on savait qu'elles allaient avoir lieu
et effectivement je rejoins les propos
tenus par le syndicaliste policier que
vous avez fait passer à l'antenne juste
avant à savoir qu on aurait peut-être
plutôt dû choisir l'option de contrôler
cette manifestation plutôt que de
l'interdire et peut-être de laisser des
choses dégénéré voilà je crois qu'il y
avait d'autres choix possibles mais
comme c'est souvent quand le souvent le
cas en matière de maintien de l'ordre à
paris et ça depuis un certain nombre de
mois voire d'années
vous dites on aurait dû éviter de voilà
je reprends mon propos de laisser les
choses dégénéré ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ça veut dire que d'une
certaine manière on laisse faire il ya
une forme de volonté là dedans j'ai pas
eu encore de retour précis sur ce qui
s'est passé
de la manifestation d'hier ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que vraisemblablement a été
mis en place dans leur à l'occasion du
rassemblement d'hier soir mêmes méthodes
qui ne fonctionne absolument pas qui
sont mises en oeuvre depuis un certain
nombre de mois dans toutes les
manifestations qui se déroulent à paris
ça a d'abord commencé avec les gilet
jaune
et puis ça s'est étendu à tous les types
de manifestations qui se sont déroulées
notamment à l'occasion des
manifestations contre la réforme la
réforme des retraites
le fait est que ces qui s'est passé hier
pour moi est la démonstration
supplémentaire un élément de plus qui
démontre qu'il ya un problème dans la
dans la politique de maintien de l'ordre
à paris et en particulier impulsée par
par le prophète police d'allemand et
qu'elle ait ce problème selon vous d'un
médecin board jugé peut-être trop
musclée de votre pas trop musclées
surtout on a le sentiment
systématiquement qui n recherche de
tension faire monter la tension faire
monter la pression pour que ça dégénère
et pour aussi peut-être servir un
discours politique qui permet ensuite de
dire vous on a entendu quelques minutes
auparavant sur votre antenne qui permet
de dire que les personnes qui
participent à cette manifestation sont
des quasi délinquants et qu' il ya une
réponse pénale du referme devrait être
prononcée à leur encontre
voilà je crois que il ya et mécanique
classique en réalité qui est à l'oeuvre
et qui pourrait ne pas être du tout
celle l'option choisie par la préfète
par le préfet de police et par par le
gouvernement on pourrait contrôler les
choses on pourrait faire différemment
pourrait tenir un discours beaucoup plus
apaisant au lieu de ça quelques heures
avant la tenue de la manifestation alors
qu'on savait qu'il se tiendrait on
savait qu'elle serait de massives
vous avez un appel une interdiction de
la part du préfet de cette manifestation
est évidemment que ça ne pouvait que
susciter une tension qui au final a
débouché sur quelques heures ce sur ce
qu'on a vu ce sont des images alors on
le rappelle un
l'un dés motifs de ce rassemblement
s'était les violences policières
présumées à la suite notamment de la
mort d' adam adama traoré
c'était il ya quatre ans a fait réagir
christophe castaner qui promet une
sanction pour chaque faute ou mot
raciste dans la police qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'intérieur à
un réel problème avec une forme de
racisme qui perdure chez certains
policiers
en réalité le ministre de l'intérieur
celui ci comme les autres tiennent un
discours qui est toujours le même qui
est celui de dire qu'ils protègent leurs
leurs troupes
évidemment évidemment qu'il dénonce le
racisme
enfin au final ce qui permet d'endiguer
ce problème qui existe dans la police
française est depuis longtemps c'est
moins les discours que les actes et la
réalité c'est que il ya très peu de
sanctions prises à l'égard des policiers
aussi parce qu'il faut dire
il ya aussi très peu de dépôts de
plainte parce que il ya eu ce
commentaire une une tendance et qui est
justifiée je crois par les faits par le
fait qu' aujourd'hui vous avez une
inefficacité de l'igpn des mécanismes de
contrôle qui existent mais qui sont
inefficaces pour véritablement en
d'idées et sanctionner enquêter et
sanctionner quand il le faut
lorsque des fautes sont constatées en
tout cas christophe castaner lui
justement défend ses troupes et ai dit
qu'il n'y a pas de tant de problèmes que
ça entre la police et la population 9
français sur 10 aurait une opinion
favorable de la police c'est parce que
nous dit un autre sondage un français
sur trois dit ne pas se sentir en
sécurité on va le voir s'afficher ce
sondage face à la police sondage yougov
pour le film fun poste aujourd'hui un
chiffre voisin qui illustre un ce
sentiment des français selon ce sondage
après ses récentes affaires qui dit vrai
qui dit faux selon vous à guillaume
martin alors moi je ne suis pas je suis
pas membre d'un institut de sondages je
sais pas qui de ces deux sages devraient
difool n 3 n'a pas pu être monétisée ce
sentiment là et il existe et il est
fondé il est fondé sur le fait que ceux
qui veulent aller en manifestation
aujourd'hui à paris en particulier mais
un peu partout en france doivent être
assez courageux pour se décider à le
faire parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
pourront être gazés ou voir matraquée 6
les pires et pour tous tous les jeunes
et en particulier les jeunes de banlieue
et disons les choses
les jeunes qui ont une peau moins clair
que d'autres pour cela il ya un risque
et c'est connu et le savent
tout le monde le sait le défenseur des
droits a sorti un rapport je croyais ou
avant-hier dans lequel il met en cause
le fait que il pointe du doigt le fait
qu'il ya des pratiques de discrimination
dans la police dans les contrôles est
évidemment dans les violences ils sont
exercées sur sur les personnes c'est une
réalité
et le problème c'est que et c'est là
qu'on peut s'inquiéter durant une fille
née du discours de du
du ministre de l'intérieur c'est que il
fait des grandes phrases sur le fait que
aucun aucun acte ne sera ne sera tous
les actes de racisme qui existeraient
serait sur la sanctionner mais sauf
qu'en même temps il tient un discours
qui consiste à dire que enfin
globalement il n'y a rien et circulez ya
rien à voir
je crois que c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
résoudre le problème il s'agit pas de
stigmatiser l'ensemble des policiers
français
mais il s'agit de regarder de manière
lucide le comportement de la police à
l'égard en particulier d'une certaine
frange de la population qui est parmi
ceux là le sondage on serait même pas un
tiers 2/3 aux trois tiers de la
population ou ou trois quarts de la
population qui considérait 100 % des
jeunes dans ces quartiers là savent
qu'ils peuvent faire l'objet de
contrôles systématiques répéter parfois
plusieurs fois dans la même journée
il ya un vrai problème ou bien on le
regarde en face tel qu'il est ou bien on
se contente de deux grandes phrases mais
en mettant la poussière sous le tapis
merci guillaume à martin d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et
s'il se veut prudent sur les projections
eric marlière sociologue maître de
conférences à l'université de lille
estime que l'indignation suscitée par la
mort de djordje flore et c'est aux états
unis pourrait créer une dynamique sur
cette question précisément en france
c'est difficile pour moi en tant que
sociologue de faire de la prospective
puisque jeu on peut regarder en arrière
ce qui se passe on peut également
faire un bilan panoramique du présent
mais c'est beaucoup plus difficile de de
nous projeter dans l'avenir cela étant
effectivement ce mouvement enfin le hier
il ya eu le collectif à damas qui a
rassemblé énormément de personnes et
paca porte de clichy puis je crois que
j'ai vu aussi dans certaines villes
françaises
effectivement on peut s'attendre
peut-être à une dynamique sur la lancée
de malheureusement de la mort de georges
soleil dans des conditions indécentes
cela étant l'historique des quartiers
populaires on montre maintenant enfin
sur les rapports conflictuels entre
jeunes et police remonte à plus de 40
ans dans les quartiers populaires
aujourd'hui c'est précisément la colère
ne retombe pas aux états unis est les
rues sont envahies de manifestants venus
témoigner leur indignation suite au
décès de georges of floyd des
rassemblements festifs inist aussi
d'émeutes des pillages des scènes de
violence que donald trump veut contrôler
grâce au déploiement de l'armée
mais son ton martial n'y change rien les
couvre feu instauré non plus les
américains sont en colère et la flore je
ferais n'est pas un cas isolé aux états
unis elles s'ajoutent s'ajoute à une
longue série de faits similaires qui ont
fait polémique ces dernières années
retour en images sur les dix cas les
plus symboliques de violences posent
pelo policières présumées à l'encontre
d'afro américains
[Musique]
vous
il
[Musique]
du tout mais
pour en parler nous sommes avec dave
bing membres du conseil d'administration
des communautés unis contre la brutalité
policière bonsoir dave vikings merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
vivait à minneapolis un non loin de
l'endroit où djordje floyd a été
interpellés depuis une semaine
telle est l'atmosphère dans la ville on
ressent enfants en tout cas depuis la
france que les choses ne s'apaise pas
alors effectivement les choses ne
s'apaisent pas et elle s'appelle seront
sans doute rapidement les gens sur place
ne sont pas satisfait par les paroles
apaisantes de certains hommes politiques
gare et les hommes ont déjà entendu et
rien n'a changé alors effectivement on
le disait minneapolis qui est devenu
l'épicentre un de la protestation contre
justement ces violences policières
gatille davantage d'inégalités dans
cette ville que dans d'autres villes du
pays au sein des états unis minneapolis
connaît les pires statistiques
s'agissant des disparités entre blancs
et noirs et autres personnes de couleur
en matière d'éducation de logement et
bien sûr de brutalité policière
et cette tendance dure depuis plusieurs
années mais les mêmes conditions
existent dans la plupart des villes des
états unis et même ailleurs c'est
pourquoi ce soulèvement s'est propagé à
d'autres villes où on connaît la même
chose
les personnes de couleur amis à police
savait que les conditions n'ont pas
changé il le voit dans la rue les
policiers les traitent mal à tous les
jours donc cela va continuer ne sommes
pas unique mais il avons effectivement
des problèmes très spéciaux ici qui ont
mené à ces situations
beaucoup d'observateurs ont parlé de
racisme ancrée
aux états unis on imagine que c'est
votre avis on l'accomplît dans vos
propos comment vous vous l'expliquer les
gens sont en colère et jean sommes très
en colère ils ont été traités de manière
horrible pendant très longtemps s en est
la conséquence les gens sont sous payés
il ya beaucoup de chômage beaucoup de
sdf
cela est une source de colère et bien
sûr il ya des opportunistes également
qu'ils rejoignaient le mouvement
mais ce que l'on peut constater
notamment c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
solidarité entre les gens les
communautés viennent en nombre aux
manifestations et le voisinage essaye de
faire le ménage après le passage des
manifestants afin de survivre et la
police ne fait rien pour protéger les
individus la police attaque surtout des
manifestants pacifiques et elle n'aide
personne d'autre au cours des nues face
et il y avait des moments où on ne
pouvait pas même espérer l'arrivée d'un
camion de pompier mais des gens essayent
de défendre leur propre maison et la
police les attaques
comment vous expliquer justement ce
divorce entre guillemets entre la
population et la police qui est supposé
protéger cette population beaucoup de
belles paroles l'on parle beaucoup des
relations entre la communauté et la
police mais ce n'est que du blabla
après les meurtres précédent il ya eu
beaucoup de paroles sur ce qu'il fallait
faire et comme la situation était
terrible on a demandé
changement notre organisation a demandé
des changements des sanctions et la
modification de la culture au sein du
département de police
nous avons été complètement ignorés
parce qu'on a souligné certains
problèmes à personne
mon conseil municipal au niveau du maire
il était prêt à réagir le statu quo est
très confortable pour beaucoup de
personnes et il est bénéficie également
à un petit nombre de personnes
donc les choses ne vont pas changer
jusqu'à ce que les gens décident de
prendre la situation en main et j'espère
au vu de la réaction à ces événements
récents qui aura enfin des changements
vous parliez tout à l'heure des paroles
apaisantes de certains politiques
évidemment non d'entendre depuis la
france surtout celle de donald trump qui
n'a rien d'un présente
donald trump voilà qui se passe du côté
de l'ordre qui veut faire intervenir
l'armée est ce que sa voix pèse beaucoup
aujourd'hui aux états unis
dans cette situation de violence n'a
quasiment aucune influence a mis la
police ou dans les grandes villes il le
fait des déclarations terrifiante
certaines de ces propositions sont
absolument celui terrifiante mais le
problème a broken à minneapolis
ce n'est pas d'un train puis n'y a pas
de république un ami n'abolisse le
problème ce sont les autorités locales
qui sont censés être libéral avec le
département de police à un département
qui défend le statut cours et le
contrôle de la population de mettre
effectivement est une source
d'inquiétude mais c'est vraiment le
moindre de nos problèmes aujourd'hui
selon vous les etats-unis sont-ils un
tournant on sortait comme nous
d'ailleurs de cette crise du comique 19
qui a mis beaucoup de gens sur le
carreau il ya beaucoup de chômage
évidemment désormais ces violences
est ce que c'est une phase il y aura un
avant et un après selon vous c'est
certainement un tournant
le virus effectivement accru les
divisions entre les personnes et j'en
suis certain cela contribue à la colère
dans les rues le chômage et les systèmes
de santé ne sont pas du tout écolo
équitable aux états unis après cette
étincelle après l'étincelle qui a
représenté ce meurtre terrible tueur de
la police on ne voit pas souvent des
vidéos de la sorte
lucas après c'était un sel il est
impossible de repartir en arrière on ne
peut pas se contrôler la situation
il faut que quelque chose craquer et
j'espère que nous sommes effectivement à
un tournant de l'histoire des états unis
il le faut merci beaucoup des vikings
membres du conseil d'administration des
communautés unis contre la brutalité
policière merci d'avoir été avec nous
depuis minneapolis rester avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons des
municipales en france les candidats
avaient jusqu'à hier pour déposer leur
candidature pour le second tour révélant
parfois des alliances surprise entre
certains partis
et puis dans viendront sur le
constructeur automobile renault ou
rentrer un prêt garanti par l'état et la
suppression de postes à venir de la
marque au losange reste incertain
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas des signes ici d'aujourd'hui en
france les cours et les violences
existait avant le confinement et pendant
ce confinement c'est vrai qu'il ya sept
ce cadre les quatre heures les taux de
féminicide a plus que je dis pas doublé
mais bien monté forcément on n'a pas
encore tous les chiffres officiels c'est
très difficile bourreau n'est jamais
n'est jamais loin finalement c'est le
confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux bras à trois
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même je
pense que c'est là la question du jour
dans quel monde on a envie de vivre il
faut on chante le terrain que c'est la
seule façon de proposer des alternatives
je pense en réalité qu' on va de plus en
plus à l'est vers le télétravail au
salon au doxa du 1er au 13 avril à 2020
83% des entreprises avaient entre 10 %
et plus de 80% de leurs collaborateurs
en télétravail d'une fantastique
opportunité et on a utilisé pour sa
insolites et la visioconférence
il ya plus que tient finalement plus
efficace le numérique est il le grand
gagnant de la crise du quotidien c'est
sûr que facebook et google ainsi qu
amazon et qui d'après nos politicards
tout révolutionner sont pour l'instant
les grands gagnants de cette ligue en
revanche nos libertés sont les grandes
perdantes c'est l'application d'un
modèle mais c'est l'application d'un
modèle qui n'est pas un autre est le
problème il vient de là
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un font 42
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe
c'est à dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant mais
on re se remet à vivre mais dans une
autre direction c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que pour
sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision à vraisemblable
pour vous ça dépend quelle valeur on
attribuait la mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes même
individuel avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral un débat éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette heure d'information deuxième
heure d'émission 21h heure de paris tout
de suite voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce mercredi 3 juin
trois semaines avant le deuxième tour
des municipales les listes sont closes à
l'issue de multiples tractations
négociations et coup de poker
les alliances sont aussi parfois
insolites paris bordeaux ou bien
clermont ferrand les candidats se
lancent les français trancheront le 28
juin tout en respectant les gestes
barrière chez le constructeur automobile
renault c'était la reprise du travail ce
matin des salariés de l'usiné de
maubeuge après des nouvelles rassurantes
selon les syndicats et ce alors que la
marque au losange officialise le prêt
garanti par l'état 2,5 milliards d'euros
sur le site de choisy-le-roi en revanche
la grève se poursuit
[Musique]
outre-manche boris johnson envisage de
proposer des passeports à des millions
d'habitants de hong kong un possible
accès à la citoyenneté britannique
objectif faire fléchir pékin qui
persistent a imposé au territoire sa loi
sur la sécurité nationale
la chine elle conseille à la partie
britannique d'abandonner et sa mentalité
de guerre froide et son état d'esprit
coloniale
[Musique]
l'italie rouvre ses frontières aux
touristes européens pas besoin de
justificatifs ni de période de
quarantaine
la france elle n'en fait pas autant
conséquences de ce manque d'harmonie
entre voisins européens certains esprits
et certains esprits s'échauffent
[Musique]
trois semaines avant le deuxième tour
des municipales l'issue du scrutin dans
plusieurs villes demeurent donc
incertaine alliance paris et
négociations en fait le point en images
sur les surprises de l'entre-deux tours
avec leïla sarraf
[Musique]
[Rires]
il pourra en parler nous sommes avec
yves d'amécourt vice président de
l'association 50 millions d'électeurs
conseiller régional lr région nouvelle
aquitaine bonsoir yves des micros merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors en avant d'évoquer ses alliances
un sondage 52 % des français n'ont pas
l'intention d'aller voter au second tour
de ces municipales c'est ce qui ressort
d'un sondage yougov pour l'obs
aujourd'hui au premier tour on rappelle
que la participation s'était établi à
seulement 44 66 %
une réaction à ce qu'il fallait
maintenir vraiment ces municipales à le
débat avait eu lieu à l'époque à notre
avis est qu'il ne fallait pas le
maintenir d'ailleurs nous avons déposé
un référé liberté auprès du conseil
d'état qui sera jugé demain pour
expliquer que ce deuxième tour en pleine
crise du cours d'un virus est entré
d'état d'urgence puisque le premier
ministre a annoncé aujourd'hui qu'il
envisageait de prolonger l'état
d'urgence au-delà du 10 juillet n'était
pas raisonnable et que cela entraînerait
un fort taux d'abstention puisqu'un
certain nombre de gens dont la santé est
fragile ou qui sont des personnes à
risque qui n'iront pas voter même si le
parlement est en train de voter une loi
pour assouplir le système des
procurations
ce qui fait que les gens pourront
préparer leur vote contrairement au
premier tour où ils ont été mis devant
le fait accompli
ce deuxième tour de scrutin sera
forcément un scrutin avec une forte
abstention et c'est dommage puisque les
élections municipales sont les élections
préféré des français est donc une
nouvelle fois on met un coup de canif
dans le suffrage universel qui est
pourtant au coeur de notre système
démocratique
alors on peut se demander quand on vous
écoute et dans ces conditions quand on
voit ce sondage
si le gouvernement est vraiment attaché
à ce qu'il y ait une forte participation
on se pose on se pose vraiment la
question et c'est dommage parce que on a
bien vu dans les crises la crise du
courant des virus ou dans la crise des
gilets jaunes que la base de la pyramide
démocratique ce sont les maires ce sont
des conseils municipaux sont les
hussards de la république ce sont des
héros du quotidien et que en défaisant
ce scrutin des élections municipales ou
en leu leu en en changeant la la qualité
est bien on est en train de toucher à
cette pyramide qui fait vraiment le la
fondation de notre l'organisation de la
nation est ce que ce sont pour vous des
élections sacrifier d'une certaine
manière oui des élections sacrifier des
élus sacrifier alors maintenant les
questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité sont au conseil
constitutionnel jusqu'à aujourd'hui 3
juin les mémoires en intervention
pouvait être remis au conseil
constitutionnel l'association 50
millions d'électeurs a remis un un
mémoire en intervention pour redire une
fois de plus tout ce qui avait manqué à
ce premier tour des élections
municipales et tout ce qui manquera au
second alors on va parler maintenant des
alliances ces accords d'appareil alors
ils sont forts
comment un pour les politiques est ce
que ce n'est pas le pire signal que l'on
puisse envoyer aux électeurs dans un
climat évidemment de défiance entre les
français et leurs responsables
politiques
effectivement les électeurs n'y
comprennent plus grand chose
il est coutume de dire au premier tour
on choisit au deuxième tour on élimine
est donc aujourd'hui face à une
coalition du parti socialiste et europe
écologie les verts parfois de la france
insoumise
il est logique que le centre de la
république en marché des républicains
salies c'est ce qui s'est passé à
bordeaux c'est ce qui s'est passé à lyon
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans un certain
nombre de villes mais c'est vrai que les
électeurs ne comprennent pas grand chose
puisque aujourd'hui
l'opposition raisonnable à la clique en
marche au parlement au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale ce sont les
républicains et donc bien sûr la
politique locale ce n'est pas la
politique nationale mais c'est très
compliqué d'expliquer aux gens sur le
terrain qu'on peut être opposé au niveau
national et alliés au niveau local vous
disiez c'est assez logique je sais pas
le terme exact que vous avez employé ces
alliances entre la république en marche
et l air vous trouvez ça justement
logique quand on voit la situation
nationale ça semble assez anachronique
finalement c'est anachronique mais au
niveau local je pense que il ya un plus
grand danger pour les villes qui serait
de donner le pouvoir à l'alliance entre
les écologistes des altermondialistes et
puis la gauche de la gauche puisque ce
qui reste du parti socialiste
aujourd'hui c'est celle à gauche de la
gauche et donc b face à cette union de
la gauche bien réflexe logique et normal
qu'ils aient de d'allier le centre avec
la droite même si c'est compliqué à
expliquer sur le terrain alors le pari
est évidemment va être scrutée un peu
plus grandes villes de france la
capitale à nina hidalgo qui va
certainement s'allier aux verts pari
gagnant pour pour la mer sans faire
finalement le trop de concessions je
pense que il ya un grand risque pour
paris et alors tout va se jouer dans la
mobilisation et dans la participation au
deuxième tour
moi je crois assez aux chances de
rachida dati de l'emporter surtout que l
a réussi à faire l'union sur son
discours et sur sa campagne ce qui
n'était pas derrière elle au premier
tour le son au second et donc je suis
assez confiant pour le score de rachida
dati
le fait qu'elle ait refusé justement
agnès buzyn la main tendue de rachida
dati c'est un handicap pour elle selon
vous ça ne va finalement pas pesé
je crois que le handicap c'est agnès
buzyn dans cette crise du coronavirus au
ministère de la santé les déclarations
qu'elle a fait avant et après sa sortie
du gouvernement ne joue pas en sa fin
heures l'espèce de suspense autour de sa
candidature qui n'était pas souhaitée
qui finalement a été validée parce que
plus personne ne veut y aller à la
république en marche qu'en fait cette
élection va être perdu pour la
république en marche
et donc voilà agnès buzyn c'est un atout
pour personne est ce que vous vous
attendez à des surprises lors de ce
scrutin
il ya toujours des surprises et les
surprises elles viendront de la
participation ou non au premier tour il
ya des listes qui se sont retrouvés avec
des scores importants parce qu'un
certain nombre d'électeurs non ont été
empêchés de voter
est ce que ses électeurs qui n'ont pas
voté au premier tour se déplaceront au
second ça peut faire bouger les lignes
et puis on a aussi la crise du
coronavirus qui joue en faveur de des
formations politiques souverainistes et
altermondialiste est ce que ça se
traduira en bulletins dans les urnes
c'est des choses qu'il faut qu'il faut
voir qu'il faudra analyser le moment
venu merci beaucoup il va d'amécourt
vice président de l'association 50
millions d'électeurs conseiller régional
lr région nouvelle aquitaine d'avoir été
avec nous reprise du travail ce matin
des salariés d'une usine renault de
maubeuge après des nouvelles rassurantes
selon les syndicats et ce alors que le
constructeur français officialise le
prêt garanti par l'état 2,5 milliards
d'euros sur le chiffre de choisy-le-roi
en revanche la grève se poursuit
grégoire pousser un sentiment de colère
c'est ce qui domine chez les salariés de
renault cette semaine en grève depuis
mardi sur le site de choisy-le-roi c'est
par le biais d'une manifestation
spontanée que les travailleurs ont
exprimé leur mécontentement ce mercredi
en cause l'annoncé de la fermeture de
l'usiné qui doit être relocalisés à
flins dans les yvelines
une décision prise par la marque au
losange dans le cadre de son plan
d'économies justifiée par la secrétaire
d'état à l'économie
agnès pannier rue nash et nous
accompagnons renault dans une des plus
graves crises de son histoire
et pour ce faire il faut accepter qu'il
y ait une partie de restructuration
cette décision suscite une vive
incompréhension chez les salariés
certains se disent prêts à aider
l'entreprise mais ils se plaignent de ne
pas avoir été consultés par la direction
tout le monde a construit autour une vie
autour de cette usine un moment repartir
sa posture peut-être mais ça sera pas ce
ne sera pas comme en attaque on est là
tu quand même pas mal d'années il ya des
années difficiles il ya des années on va
dire heureuse où tout va bien encore ça
va pas tout le monde est prêt à
donner un coup de main c'est notre
entreprise on est on est là pour la
faire vivre aussi
donc on peut comprendre qu'aujourd'hui à
des difficultés dès qu'il faut y faire
face
il faut expliquer les choses j'attends
des réponses
on attend tous des réponses à nos
questions savoir pourquoi le site de
renault choisit qui incite rentable va
être délocalisée sur flins en sachant
que nous on habite tous aux alentours
pour que 70 km de choisy alors ça paraît
peut-être pas loin sur la carte mais en
région parisienne ça nous fait deux
heures 12 heures et demie aller deux
heures deux heures et demie retour c'est
impossible on a les structures on a les
infrastructures déjà on a les vapes au
concentrateur en atout on a les fosses
pour on a tout ce qu'il faut on a le
personnel qui est fort mais qui est
compétent donc voilà qui nous expliquent
pourquoi ils vont nous délocaliser sur
flammes
rejoints par des salariés d'autres
usines en france sandouville ou encore
doux et ils étaient plus de 300 en
compagnie de leurs responsables
syndicaux
parmi eux philippe martinez qui a fait
la majeure partie de sa carrière chez
renault
le secrétaire général de la cgt est venu
prêter main forte aux employés du
constructeur automobile
c'est le cinquième plan de compétitivité
cherono cinquième depuis 15 ans parle
pas des précédents on va en rester à 15
ans est ce que la marque se porte mieux
est ce que les salariés de renault sont
plus nombreux est ce que les conditions
de travail se sont améliorées
je pense qu'il faudrait entre guillemets
faire un procès je dis bien entre
guillemets un procès de tous les anciens
pdg et notamment le dernier
célèbre pour son évasion du japon mais
célèbre aussi pour son salaire célèbre
aussi pour les dividendes qu'il a versé
aux actionnaires
célèbre pour le nombre d'emplois qui l'a
supprimé et les l'exploitation peut pas
dire autre chose qu'il a exercées sur
les salariés dans le monde entier le
montant du plan d'économies de renault
se chiffre à plus de 2 milliards d'euros
il prévoit de supprimer 4600 postes sur
le territoire national soit 10% des
effectifs
une manifestation est prévue samedi
après midi pour poursuivre le mouvement
de contestation
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec benjamin cucq journalistes
automobiles
auteur du livre noir de renault aux
éditions first bonsoir benjamin cuche
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france l'état qui va donc garantir
ce fameux prêts est ce que cela peut
acter la survie de renault selon vous ce
n'est finalement qu'une étape renouveau
mourir sont soit arrêtées avec 7
cette idée au que renault puisse mourir
nos récents 20 ans c'est à dire de près
10% des distances même de la france
un peu plus même renault ne va pas
mourir c'est un à la traversée deux ans
de guerre des crises traversées plein
entreprises faut juste qu'elles se
recentre sur son coeur de métier qui est
la voiture deux segments à b et c
voilà ok la règle dans des délires de
construction de plein de types
différents de véhicules ça veut dire que
renault est quand même un petit peu
condamnés à se réinventer en tout cas se
retrouver
oui mais en même temps c'est logique si
on produit les voitures dans un endroit
et qu'on produit moins en moins de
voitures dans un dans un endroit mais
qu'on produit des pièces dans 11 pays
c'est à dire la france en france jean ii
choisi comme une usine de co dans ses
usines de pièces on les produits et pour
des voitures qui sont finalement
assemblée en turquie en roumanie au
maroc ou ailleurs
waouh insomnies à un moment fabrique pas
de pièce c'est un peu comme la
sidérurgie
on a toujours produit moins de voitures
en france et on annonce est plein de la
baisse de la sidérurgie de la production
d'acier à un moment on produit là on a
besoin des pièces c'est assez cohérent
que renault va y supprimer des usines
qui ne produisent une pièce qui
produisent des pièces pour des voitures
qui sont fabriquées ailleurs
effectivement ça c'est sur l'aspect
réalité et pragmatisme
ces salariés bon ça c'est moi votre
domaine effectivement c'est le social
mais voilà ces salariés on comprend leur
colère et leur désarroi alors leur
colère est complètement compréhensible
la colère est complètement complètement
compréhensible mais je vais je vais être
une fois n'est pas coutume totalement
d'accord avec monsieur martinez
quand il dit qu'il faudrait faire un
procès aux
à l'ancien savary à l'ancien jaillir
salariés à l'ancien mandataire social de
l'entreprise c'est-à-dire carlos ghosn
qui est responsable de ce fatras qui est
responsable de tout ça mais c'est mêlée
en même temps on peut aussi s'interroger
sur les anciens dirigeants
je les anciens je l'avais déjà dit et
votre compte est le seul ministre de
l'économie qui s'est opposé à carlos
ghosn
c'est emmanuel macron avant et
maintenant le manant bruno bruno le
maire en temps en temps un peu imposée
en temps un peu s'imposer vis-à-vis de
la direction de renault et entrons
conditionner les aides aux à
l'intégration au maintien de l'emploi
mais avant les dizaines de ministres
qu'on a eu aussi bien à droite qu'à
gauche on laissait les clés lui ont
laissé les clefs de la kangoo au
président au président gones j'allais y
venir
c'était mes prochaines questions carlos
ghosn ce plan s'est réellement son
héritage assez totalement son héritage
le plan actuel est totalement l'héritage
de carlos ghosn si carlos ghosn n'avait
pas commis autant de malfaisance
d'entreprise de casse sociale dans
l'organisation même de la destruction de
l'emploi de renault on n'en serait pas
là
geslin ses chiens il avoue il a eu un
délire de vouloir être numéro un du
numéro un de l'automobile mondiale
en agrégeant renault ou toyota pato
contre toyota en agrégeant renault
nissan lada mais toutes les toutes les
marques du groupe renault nissan en
disant on est numéro 1 mais comme si la
2ème médaille c'est pas les jo avec
numéro un de l'automobile on n'a pas une
prime on n'a pas c'est juste honteux son
délire mégalomaniaque fait finalement
basse et les ouvriers qui ne payent les
salariés et les salariés tout largement
toute la production qu'ils payent pas ce
qu a pas eu de ya plus de synergie qui a
été mise au kunst énergie n'a été mise
en place
rien n'a été réfléchi si lui il était
justement son délire et son ca volonté
de gagner beaucoup d'argent sur le dos
sur le dos tout le monde est si bien de
l'état
c'est à trouver hockey parce que l'état
quand il supprime des postes chez
renault qu'est ce qu'ils payent les
chômeurs bas c'est l'état qu'il était
derrière justement effectivement renault
vous dites voilà c'est une entreprise
qui a 120 ans qui va jamais mourir enfin
est ce que c'est une bonne chose
que ce constructeur français vivent sous
perfusion de l'état et ne trouve pas ça
prend propre autonomie pour sortir la
tête de l'eau c'est très français tout
de même c'est très français mais en même
temps ça fait soixante quinze ans groen
envie son intervention de l'état depuis
sa nationalisation renaud vit sous
perfusion de l'état
renault a été nationalisée parce que
louis renault était un collabo du régime
nazi
l'histoire est écrite le général de
gaulle a décidé de nationaliser renault
pour cette raison le et depuis renault
renault a toujours été toujours été
assez représentative de l'état de la
nation
même quand il était encore renault va
bien la france va bien quand la france
voit moins bien renault va moins bien et
vice versa aujourd'hui comment vous
voyez les choses pour cette entreprise
comment vous jugez fait stratégie je
pense qu'elle est je pense dans le
détail
déjà il faut voir une chose c'est que le
canard enchaîné annonce l éventualité de
cas de fermetures d'usinés
on en est à une seule ce qui est une
bonne chose le président ancien art est
quelqu'un de bonne volonté visiblement
c'est ce qu'on appelle un honnête homme
c'est pas c'est pas un type qui omnubilé
par sa gloriole personnelle et c'est
l'argent donc déjà ces deux bons points
après la stratégie va recentrer les
véhicules recentrer des véhicules sur
une gamme qui marche c'est pas une
mauvaise idée je viens supprimez
supprimez les mets véhicule type
monospace de la gamme et augmenter le
nombre de bébés suv ne peut être que
bénéfices arnould ne peut être que
bénéfique pour quoi nous parlons
aujourd'hui que peuvent craindre le plus
est les salariés à part évidemment ce
qui arrive à ceux de choisy le roi est
ce que les autres doivent craindre une
baisse de salaire pour sauver
l'entreprise
non je pense pas je pense pas qu'il
faille craindre une baisse de salaire
pour sauver l'entreprise
pour de multiples raisons à commencer
par la première c'est que les salaires
chez renault dont j'ai à part celui
carlos ghosn n'ont jamais été n'ont
jamais été délirant c'est une pierre
dreyfus qui était le président
historique de renault avait
20 salaire de 1 à 12 par rapport au
salaire du petit cherono a été longtemps
une pyramide écrasé a longtemps été la
politique salariale de renault c'est à
dire des salaires pas très élevées m
assez bas en bas de l'échelle mais pas
très haut
tout en haut de l'échelle ça ça a été
mis à mis à mal par des médias lomani
carlos ghosn mais globalement on va
c'est difficile de tondre de 3,9 donc je
pense pas que les salaires de mai de ses
seize ouvriers de ses salariés puissent
être remis en cause
merci benjamin qu'une journaliste
automobile auteurs du livre noir de
renault éditions first d'avoir été avec
nous six cent mille personnes ont
téléchargé l'application stop kobe
depuis hier la pandémie de coronavirus a
changé de nombreuses habitudes parmi
elles le recours à la télémédecine en
forte augmentation
un phénomène qui inquiète certains
médecins tandis que le ministère de la
santé voit lui dans cette médecine 2.0
une solution aux déserts médicaux
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
oh
la téléconsultation est ce la fin des
déserts médicaux
peut-être je n'ai pas de tabou
[Musique]
oh
c'est avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du royaume uni qui
pourrait proposer des passeports hors
hong kong est impossible l'accès à la
citoyenneté britannique et puis la
direction l'italie qui a rouvert
aujourd'hui ses aéroports et ses
frontières aux voyageurs de l'union
européenne
[Musique]
l'afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais ne
sont pas encore au niveau où se trouve
par exemple l'europe ou les états unis
qu'à la stratégie vous avez déployés
dans le sud kivu pour limiter la
propagation du virus on a proposé à ce
qu'est le confinement puisse être
sélectif est concerné seulement des
personnes âgées à haut risque de
complication pour sensibiliser la
population ça l'est beaucoup plus
facilement puisqu'on venait de sortir
d'une épidémie à ebola qui exige
également la distanciation social lavage
des mains que si on aura affaire à deux
épidémies aussi dangereuse qui est beau
la et coronavirus ça pourrait être très
très difficile pour nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant mais on re se remet à
vivre mais dans une autre direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision à vraisemblable
pour vous ça dépend quelle valeur on
attribue à la mort et à la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral un débat éthique
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
où
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois est ce qu'on sait combien
d'enfants sont victimes de ces violences
et qui sont concernés par ces drames qui
se déroule dans le huis clos familial
pendant la période actuelle il est
difficile de dire précisément combien
d'enfants sont concernés car en fait on
a très peu de visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le dise
ils redisent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il n'y a plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude elles
portent plutôt sur ce que nous voyons
pas la partie immergée de l'iceberg en
fait parce que les très difficile pour
les enfants malgré tout d'appeler le
même et dans ce cas là on n'entend rien
ça se fait totalement dans le silence
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques et sur ces sujets sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon intéresse dans
la crise ducobu 19
c'est toute une chaîne décisionnelle
médicales administratives et politiques
qui est responsable du fisc alors que
l'on aime s recommandait le port du
masque par les populations la parole
publique a longtemps menti sur sa
nécessité pour ne pas avoir la triste
absence du stock vie la décision de
confinement s'imposait compte-tenu du
manque de matériel permettant d'autres
solutions mais en freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise les connaît l'état ne pourra
plus est l'état providence que nous
avons que pour anne aura été cimetière
de certaines espérances en pensant que
le progrès faisait de nous des hommes
dieu et que les technocrates avec les du
monde demain des conséquences de la
crise oblige à repenser nos modèles la
découverte du télétravail l'intérêt de
consommer des produits locaux le besoin
de solidarité vont faire évoluer une
population qui a découvert qu'elle était
mortel
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce que si seul un père dit
d'interdire
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez 21h30 heure française londres
envisage de proposer des passeports à
des millions d'habitants de hong kong un
possible accès à la citoyenneté
britannique
objectif faire fléchir la chine qui a
récemment adopté une loi sur la sécurité
nationale contesté par une partie de
l'archipel
les précisions de jordi demory la chine
rappelle à l'ordre le royaume uni pékin
exhorte londres à cesser toute ingérence
dans les affaires hongkongaise on est
derrière nous conseillons au royaume uni
de prendre du recul d'abandonner sa
mentalité de guerre froide et son esprit
colonial et de reconnaître et respecter
le fait que hong kong est revenu est une
région administrative spéciale de la
chine il devrait se conformer au droit
international et aux principes
fondamentaux des relations
internationales et cesser immédiatement
d'interférer dans les affaires de hong
kong et les affaires intérieures de la
chine
sinon ça se retournera contre eux une
sortie qui fait suite aux propos tenus
ce mardi par boris johnson
le premier ministre britannique demande
aux autorités chinoises de renoncer à
appliquer la loi controversée sur la
sécurité nationale dans le territoire
autonome
il annonce également qu'il pourrait
proposer à plusieurs millions de hong
kong et des passeports et un possible
accès à la citoyenneté britannique si
pékin maintient cette loi de nombreuses
personnes à hong kong craignent que leur
mode de vie que la chine s'est engagée à
maintenir ne soit menacée si la chine
impose sa loi sur la sécurité nationale
le gouvernement britannique modifiera sa
législation sur l'immigration elle
permettra à tout détenteur de ces
passeports résidant à hong kong de venir
au royaume uni pour une période
renouvelable de 12 mois est d'obtenir
d'autres droits y compris le droit de
travailler ce qui les mettrait sur la
voie de la citoyenneté la grande
bretagne n'aurait alors pas d'autre
choix que de maintenir ses profonds
liens d'histoire et d'amitié avec le
peuple de hong kong
outre le royaume-uni les etats-unis
l'australie et le canada ont public
exprimé leurs craintes concernant
l'adoption de cette loi le texte obtenu
le feu vert du parlement chinois mais il
n'est pas encore finalisé il prévoit de
punir les activités séparatistes
terroriste la subversion ou encore les
ingérences étrangères à hong kong un
projet législatif en réaction aux
nombreuses manifestations anti pékin qui
ont ébranlé le territoire autonome
depuis 2019
en visite dans la capitale chinoise pour
une réunion avec de hauts fonctionnaires
car ilham la chef de l'exécutif de hong
kong a pour sa part relativisé les
préoccupations internationales
et bien je peux vous dire que la
communauté internationale et certains
gouvernements étrangers ont
manifestement adopté deux poids deux
mesures pour faire face à ce problème et
pour traiter ce sujet il est de la
compétence légitimes de tous pays de
promulguer des lois pour protéger et
sauvegarder la sécurité nationale les
états unis ne font pas exception à cette
règle
pas plus que le royaume uni alors
pourquoi devrait-il s'opposer résister
ou même condamné et prendre des
sanctions contre hong kong et la
république populaire de chine pour avoir
pris les mesures similaires pour
protéger cette visite en chine de la
chef de l'exécutif de hong kong n'est
pas anodine
la loi sur la sécurité dans le
territoire autonome pourrait être
présentée au comité permanent de
l'assemblée nationale populaire
dès la fin du mois de juin et jean
françois di mailhiot et le président de
l'institut de recherche asia centre
selon lui le premier ministre
britannique joue un jeu dangereux avec
pékin bon il zone jaune pour toutes
sortes d'autres raisons aujourd'hui en
particulier parce qu'il se dit
probablement fatal en venant de hong
kong serait les talents intéressant à
récupérer lors d'une angleterre qui fait
face aux briques side
il vient il a changé d'avis ce sera
difficile bien sûr de ne pas accepter
cela
sans faire une crise avec pékin c'est en
tout cas courageux parce qu'il lave il
ouvre la possibilité d'une crise avec
pékin aucun grand pays occidental n'a
aujourd'hui ouvert à ce niveau là alors
il va faire constater quelle est
l'ampleur du différend qu'il ouvre avec
pékin au moment où il le fait s'il a
effectivement
le la tenue et si d'ici là d'endurance
pour maintenir relatifs à frottement
avec pékin ce n'est pas en effet
d'annonce et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis leicester avec alister
jones professeur associé politiques à
l'université de montfort de leicester
c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir alister jones perd 6 d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france comment
peut-on analyser cette proposition de
boris johnson
je pense que pourrais-je personnes
essayent d'avancer très prudemment entre
la proposition où l'offre du droit aux
citoyens à hong kong et qui ont le droit
depuis 1999 82 1997 et venir vivre au
raid me sens trop contrarier le
gouvernement chinois
le problème c'est la façon dont le
gouvernement chinois réagi cela va bien
au delà de l'accord était annulé lorsque
comme hong kong a été rétrocédée à
l'époque on pensait que ce serait un
état de système on pensait qu'on aurait
une certaine souplesse et pourrait se
trouver renée dans une certaine mesure
cette loi de sécurité nationale a adopté
à beijing montre que la chine rôle des
muscles et essaye de saper le système
mis en place jusqu'à en 2047 au moins
par le royaume
donc on peut dire que la chine un frein
l'accord décidées lors de la
rétrocession de hong kong donc si on
vous écoute bien c'est une sorte de
lutte de pouvoir qui se joue là de lutte
d'influencé en quelque sorte oui
du point de vue de pourrissent hewson il
y à beaucoup d'autres problèmes son
cours il ya le pré xiti mialot
coronavirus et voilà quelque chose qui
s'y ajoutent encore on pourrait penser
qu'il insiste là-dessus parce que les
deux autres problèmes se développent
très mal il y aura sans doute pas
d'accord pour l'autre exit et la
situation avec le coronavirus est
désastreuse oreilles non mais
avec hong kong il peut dire regardez je
suis un dirigeant à l'échelle mondiale
et j'agis en tant que dirigeant
britannique
il s'agit de renforcer ou de rappeler le
statut britannique dans le monde selon
bret johnson alors vous l'avez dit
effectivement on rappelle évidemment
hong kong ancienne colonie d rétrocédée
à la chine en 1997 la chine elle parle
d'esprit colonies là de la part du
royaume uni n'y at-il pas effectivement
une forme d'ingérence dans cette
proposition par les johnson le problème
c'est que l'accord conclu en 1997 a
commencé bien plus tôt
les britanniques et les chinois sont
tombés d'accord sur la façon de
gouverner en compte le royaume uni ne
souhaitait pas ça n'a pas permis qu'il
n'y aurait pas d' indépendance complète
pour satisfaire le gouvernement chinois
mais en contrepartie hong kong avait
beaucoup d'autonomie et le rôle le duo
rémy nice est de s'assurer que cette
autonomie reste des citoyens kong et des
passeports britanniques d'outre-mer où
sont éligibles pour ce passeport ils
peuvent se rendre au royaume uni y
travailler jusqu'à six mois et cela
pourrait être étendue jusqu'à 12 mois
donc il ya effectivement une relation
étroite entre conques et le royaume uni
en tant qu'ancienne puissance coloniale
et on pourrait dire que l'effectif en
une obligation de venir défendre le
peuple
hong kong et c'est ce que boris johnson
semble penser alors dans le même temps
brice jeunes sont un petit peu aussi le
grand défenseur du break site pas
nécessairement donc envers en faveur de
l'ouverture
quel intérêt à ce premier ministre
britannique aujourd'hui à tendre la main
un pays encore plus lointain même si
vous venez très bien l'expliquer il ya
des liens historiques très étroit je
voulais tout cela concerne les
passeports les personnes qui ont ce
passeport britannique d'outre-mer
peuvent se rendre
mini il y en a environ 350 milles mais
il y en a il pourrait y en avoir au
total 3 millions qui peuvent venir se
rendre à travailler au royaume-uni donc
boris johnson essayent de protéger des
personnes qui a possède le passeport de
son pays
du point de vue britannique la chine
enfreint va à l'encontre de la corse si
cette loi de sécurité nationale est
imposé à hong kong alors cela irait à
l'encontre des droits des citoyens en
congrès pour une bourriche johnson il
s'agit de protéger chine presque des
ressortissants britanniques des
personnes qui ont un passeport
britannique
comment cette proposition et elle a
accueilli outre-manche par la population
en majorité on n'en parle pas beaucoup
cela fait quelques gros titres mais il y
à d'autres préoccupations le coronavirus
est bien plus important le président
aussi pour beaucoup de personnes
cela dit concernant la possibilité
d'accueillir trois millions de personnes
au royaume-uni certaines personnes se
demandent si comme un essai de fermer
les frontières avec le brésil
cela ne représenterait pas le risque
d'avoir un afflux de migrants qui
attaquent obtiendrez la la citoyenneté
pourrait travailler sur le marché
britannique
donc certaines personnes se demandent
quel est le plan au long terme et
certaines personnes ne considère que le
gouvernement lui même ne sait pas ce que
ce qu'est son plein au long terme
merci à lyster jones professeur associé
de politique à l'université de montfort
de leicester d'avoir été avec nous pour
vu de l'extérieur ce soir
la crise du coronavirus et le
déconfinement en europe l'italie rouvre
aujourd'hui ses aéroports et ses
frontières aux voyageurs de l'union
européenne et de l'espace schengen et ce
sans quarantaine objectif affiché de
rome faire revenir au plus vite les
touristes le secteur touristique
représente 13 % du pib de la botte mais
des mesures pourront être prises ce dont
je cite un éventuel risque
épidémiologique est la france elle n'a
en revanche toujours pas rouvert ses
frontières conséquences de ce manque
d'harmonie entre voisins européens
certains esprits s'échauffent réaction
par exemple de frontaliers à menton on
peut y aller mais on peut pas rentrer on
peut pas rentrer en france
alors c'est pour rester là-bas bloqué à
l'appel
pendant que nous on était interdit de
rentrer en italie les italiens ils
pouvaient rentrer en france en toute
impunité sans contrôle sans rien alors
que nous on nous a toujours interdit
d'entrer en italie maintenant que les
frontières sont ouvertes qu'on nous a
informé hier que ça sera ouvert
aujourd'hui il ya des problèmes et ben
oui apparemment il ya des gens qui font
demi tour mais comme on ne sait pas
pourquoi j'ai failli faire demi-tour
moi-même et tenter éventuellement par la
frontière du duo mais si on nous si on
nous refoulons ne refoule vous pouvez
passer du côté italien pour revenir
il vous faudra une attestation
international de circulation il vous
faudra de surcroît une attestation de
domicile votre carte d'identité et un
motif valable et non food in d'être allé
en italie sans quoi vous risquez 135
euros d'amande et pour en parler nous
sommes avec météo jose alberti rédacteur
en chef de putsch médias bonsoir météo
gisèle berti on a entendu ce ce désarroi
à ses frontaliers qui sont un petit peu
dépité de ne pas pouvoir faire
l'aller-retour on les comprendre comment
on peut expliquer ce manque d'harmonie
entre deux pays aussi proches et membres
de l'union européenne
tout simplement parce que là les règles
de schengen sont valables sur mon compte
et il convient aux pays européens
on a déjà vu non mais en particulier
entre la france et l'italie qu'il ya eu
déjà des tensions pour d'autres raisons
liées à l'immigration clandestine depuis
hier au moins deux ans quand des
gendarmes et français se sont retrouvés
aussi sur le territoire italien pour
refouler des migrants donc cette ce
problème de là
du retour en france des français qui
légitimement on veut aller faire leurs
courses en italie représentent en tout
cas un problème un problème de manque de
coordination
mais aussi de comment dire d'un point de
vue un peu étroit que qu'on garde en
france au niveau national de naissance
qu'il ya des zones comme celle justement
à la frontière avec l'italie qui
pourrait être autorisé à un mouvement un
peu plus flexible
parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier que
l'italie est le premier pays qui a fermé
qui est passé dans le lot d'armes comme
on l'appelle en anglais l'italie a
désormais le 8 mars si on considère
certains régions et le 9 pour le reste
du pays donc on est dans une phase un
peu avancée par rapport la france mais
avec la france on partage le fait que
l'épidémie est descendu je suis pas en
mesure de dire si elle est effectivement
c'est là effectivement disparu mais de
toute façon il y a plus de signes de 2,2
comment dire de diffusion de cette série
russe de façon préoccupante
on y reviendra justement parce que c'est
intéressant ce point là mais je voulais
finir sur ce sur ses frontières
cette situation ne montrent pas là
justement les limites de l'europe et de
schengen complètement il ne faut pas
oublier que l'europe a été pratiquement
absente dans cette crise sanitaire et
quand tu es là
fait un signal et quand elle est
intervenue en général elle a provoqué
des problèmes parce que en particulier
du point de vue des italiens
l'intervention de la commission
européenne a été tardive est très limité
et même agaçante
parce que de toute façon il y a eu des
pays que la légitimité de leur
indépendance et souveraineté ont fermé
les frontières à l'italie et donc ça
c'est consulter d'ailleurs avec le
gouvernement de rome ou très peu et sans
se préoccuper des conséquences aussi
économique qui pouvait avoir aussi sur
leurs économies
parce que il ne faut pas oublier que il
y à des décharges très important avec
les pays frontaliers donc la slovénie
l'autriche et et la suisse est
naturellement la france mais de toute
façon disons que cette crise sanitaire a
rappelé aussi aux supporters disons de
schengen donc la libre circulation que
les frontières existent et qu'elles
peuvent être utilisés aussi endiguer une
pandémie alors vous parler d'économie
l'italie sur ce coup là peut-être
prendre l'avancé parce que il ya un
enjeu évidemment de taille c'est celui
du tourisme
les italiens évidemment en ont besoin
cruellement
la france elle aimerait bien peut-être
garder ces français chez elle cet été
oui sans doute c'est un discours qui se
comprend mais en même temps on a un
problème alors de liberté de circulation
des citoyens parce que si on empêche aux
citoyens français d'aller où ils veulent
on pense d'un côté qui est peut-être ils
ne sont pas assez adulte assez mature
pour choisir ce qui est bien pour eux et
puis on dire on adopte un
protectionnisme que c'est légitime si on
veut
et qui va contre les principes de
l'union européenne qui sont toujours
comment dire soutenue surtout par
certains gouvernements européens comme
celui français
il ne faut pas oublier aussi une autre
chose que même à l'intérieur de l'italie
la décision d'ouvrir la circulation à
terme internes entre toutes les régions
a suscité des polémiques et des craintes
parce que certains gouverneurs des
régions notamment du sud ont eu peur de
voir débarquer par exemple de lombarde
donc du nord où il ya eu les principaux
foyers de la maladie mais en même temps
on sait on a trouvé des façons de régler
la question aussi avec naturellement là
un système qui est prêt à intervenir si
on voit que il y aura d'autres autos
manifestation du virus ce mercredi météo
jose alberti marque également le retour
on vous l'avait évoqué de la liberté de
déplacement entre ces fameuses 20
régions
c'est vraiment la vie normale racontez
nous un petit peu la situation en italie
à l'instar de la france on a le
sentiment que que l'épidémie va m'en
marque le pas le virus circule mais
l'épidémie s'éloigne
certains médecins exter virologues
italien on dit que la lépi déni elle
virus a disparu du point de vue clinique
mais en ce qui concerne les italiens il
y as sans doute l' envie de reprendre à
vivre un peu plus normalement mais tout
en respectant les distanciation et les
plus possible mais il faut dire aussi
que
il ya on a assisté par exemple à des
scènes où certains places italiennes ont
été remplis par des manifestants contre
le gouvernement comptait notamment à
rome ou à milan et aussi des places ou
une balle et les personnes se sont
rassemblées par exemple pour accueillir
le président de la république dans la
ville des coloniaux qui a été visitée
hier qui était le jour de la fête
nationale pour la naissance de la
république et donc on a vu des gens qui
étaient s'est rassemblée peut-être
qu'ils étaient à une distance inférieure
à 1 mètre mais ils avaient pratiquement
toutes les
les masques et et l'utilisation de ceux
de ce système de protection de ceux de
cet outil de production semble assez
bien fonctionné
merci matteo jose alberti d'avoir été
avec nous avoir évoqué cette situation
en italie le brésil à présent et sa
situation sanitaire plus de 30000 morts
dus aux coronavirus le pays recense près
de 1300 nouveaux décès lors de ces
dernières 24 heures il s'agit de la
journée la plus meurtrière depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire +29 1000
nouvelles contaminations également en un
jour l'amérique du sud
on va les pistons ducobu de 19 depuis
une dizaine de jours selon l oms et
écoutez l'analyse de franck gaudichaud
professeur en histoire et civilisation
d'amérique latine à l'université
toulouse jean jaurès avait sans aucun
doute que la stratégie du président
molson à eau à 10 on approfondit et
démultiplier et compris la la crise
gigantesque qui s'abat en ce mouvement
sur le brésil après évidemment la
pandémie elle arrive dans un terrain
social politique très complexe les
inégalités très forte de ce pays des
plus fortes au monde
évidemment dans les favelas quand on n'a
pas accès à l'eau
la pandémie se développe énormément on a
aussi dans une situation avec un système
sanitaire qui est très fragilisée et
effectivement la politique fédérale donc
la politique de gaulle sonar ou
approfondie à responsable aujourd'hui il
est responsable politiquement de
l'ampleur de la contagion vous l'avez
dit la moitié des cas latino américains
se trouve au brésil
un demi million de personnes infectées
plus de 30000 morts officiellement on
pense que c'est beaucoup plus le brésil
en fait vignes crise politique
institutionnelle très profonde
avant même bol son héros depuis 2016 on
se rappelle la destitution de la
présidente dilma rousseff est depuis son
arrivée il ya une tension très forte
entre le président d'extrême droite
entouré en partie de l'est des
militaires le parlement la cour suprême
et les gouverneurs locaux qui eux
certains d'entre eux en tout cas veulent
appliquer des mesures de quarantaine
suivre les recommandations de l'om est
ce donc
il ya effectivement une très grande
tension et on a vu encore ces derniers
jours molson arrow participer à des
réunions publiques y compris de ses
partisans contre les institutions
parlementaires et ils y participent
comme les autres sans masque sans
mesures barrières donc il ya une crise
sociale et politique et la pandémie
finalement bien catalyser encore un peu
plus l'ampleur de la crise et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivi prochain point complet sous la
forme d'un journal classique dans
quelques minutes j'aurais le plaisir de
vous retrouver pour cette émission
demain soir à 20h est évidemment dans
quelques minutes pour le journal
[Musique]
je pense que c'est là la question du
jour dans quel monde on a envie de vivre
il faut on chante le terrain que c'est
la seule façon de proposer des
alternatives
je pense en réalité qu' on va de plus en
plus à l'est vers le télétravail ont
selon oddo que ça du 1er au 13 avril à
2020 83% des entreprises avaient entre
10 % et plus de 80% de leurs
collaborateurs en télétravail deal
fantastique opportunité et on a utilisé
pour sa insolites etc et la
visioconférence
il ya bien finie mans plus efficace